bonjour cesse duclos bonjour alan wiley
bonjour à tous ceux qui nous écoutent
bon avec cette annonce aujourd'hui la
finalement vous envoyer le signal que
les canadiens peuvent se remettre à
voyage
non j'ai pas tout à fait le signal qu'on
a qu'on envoie parce que la conseil
reste la même ce n'est pas encore le
temps de voyager on est encore un
pandémie le virus circule les variants
aussi une grande partie des canadiens
ont déjà reçu une première dose c'est
autour de 75% les 12 ans et plus 20 % à
peu près ont déjà reçu une deuxième dose
comme vous d'ailleurs mais on n'est pas
rendu à la fin la pandémie faut donc
être très prudent est restée au pays
sauf pour des raisons essentielles oui
mais malgré tout puisqu'on fait l'idée
leur tour pour les gens qui ont eu leurs
deux dons de vaccins plus de quarantaine
pour les saisons avec ce n'est deux fois
ça vient quand même motiver les gens et
déjà qu'un grand des piscines voyage
alors beaucoup manqué ils vont utiliser
cette opportunité là oui on comprend
qu'on a tous envie de retrouver le con
c'était avant la pandémie mon époque on
commentait avant la pandémie la pandémie
toujours avec nous il faut donc être
plus loin ici même au pays mais aussi à
l'étranger des pays en dehors du canada
qui ont des situations sanitaires
beaucoup pire que celle du canada donc
été extrêmement prudent évidemment il ya
des mesures qui sont plus adaptés pour
ce qu'ils doivent ou qui veulent revenir
au pays et ça exclut comme vous l'avez
dit si on est pleinement vacciner de ne
pas passer dans un hôtel et de ne pas
faire la quarantaine si au test du
retour on est négative des récollets non
las illas est à l'image du sel avec le
québec par contre sur les conditions
pour éviter la quarantaine parce qu'au
québec on considère qu'avant rue la
coved une fois plus une seule dose de
vaccin censé être pleinement vacciner
c'est l'équivalent c'est parce qu'on
reconnaît avec les autorités fédérales
est-ce qu'il va falloir travailler un
peu le message est ce qu'on va pouvoir
faire des ajustements parce que déjà
qu'ils ont eu l'écho abîme qui aurait eu
une seule dose de vaccin
j'ai pas les mêmes règles que les autres
alors qu'au québec on dit que ça fait la
même chose
trois choses ici la première c'est que
la science n'est pas encore totalement
clair là dessus
android sur combien de temps on est
protégé contre accords et du moins
partiellement en fonction du moment où
on a eu la coved et ce que les gens
quand ils
dans la ville 2020 sont encore bien
protégé en juin 2021
donc la science qui n'a pas encore parlé
clairement et les experts se penchaient
suis là ces jours ci la deuxième chose
c'est que le québec est la seule
province à avoir adopté cette politique
est comme une étude fédération il faut
travailler avec l'ensemble des provinces
et la troisième chose c'est que les
discussions avec le gouvernement du
québec vont très très bien et on espère
pour montrer des progrès au cours des
prochains jours mais vous convenez qu'un
arrimage qui doit se faire on peut pas
rester avec une règle comme ça c'est
comme s'il y avait deux breaks à
l'intérieur du même pays et d'essayer
les progrès qui doivent être faites
exactement pour les raisons que vous
venez de bons parents des enfants parce
que l'on sait ça fait sourciller un
petit peu on dit les adultes vaccinés de
doses vont pouvoir échapper à la
quarantaine évidemment si leur test est
négatif mais les enfants ils peuvent pas
se faire vacciner donc pour eux la
quarantaine est obligatoire écouter un
enfant mineur évidemment le sera pas
tout seul faire sa quarantaine ça va
prendre quelqu'un pour le surveiller
leur part du temps se sépara donc ça
revient peu ou même les parents se
retrouvent avec une quarantaine il ya
même l'association des transporteurs
leur en avion qui dit becqueter c'est de
la discrimination soit pour les enfants
mais à nouveau trois jours une pandémie
donc il faut continuer très prudent et
les voyages à l'étranger sont fortement
déconseillés la deuxième chose c'est que
tout le monde et pas vacciner deux fois
on ne peut pas été entre autres ce sont
des 15% des objectifs qu'on s'est donné
pour va passer à d'autres d'étape
la troisième chose c'est que
malheureusement effectivement les
enfants de 12 ans qui ne peuvent pas
être vaccinés sont quand même
potentiellement porteurs du virus et des
d'orient et il faut protéger tout le
monde et c'est vrai que c'est très
incommodant de d'être de sauver y ait
des enfants de moins de 12 ans là pour
s'assurer qu'ils font leur quarantaine
mais c'est ce qu'il faut faire
certains noms au cours des prochaines
semaines si on revient au pays
maintenant parlons des touristes là
c'est une règle qui est bonne pour les
canadiens qui vont revenir de l'étranger
donc je retrouvais plus facile moins
coûteux aussi pour les touristes
est ce que ça veut dire que c'est sont
vaccinés de donzy pas venir ici visiter
le canada
non ça ne change rien pour les touristes
tout ce qui change maintenant ce sont
les conditions de retour au canada des
canadiens ou des résidents permanents
les frontières restent fermées pour les
voyages
non essentiels et donc pour des voyages
touristiques bon est-ce que ça risque de
créer un effet pervers tout ça pour
l'industrie touristique canadienne c'est
à dire même si vous recommander pas les
voyages on a bien vu dans le temps des
fêtes ce n'est pas plus recommandé les
voyages vont à des canadiens qui ont
voyagé
alors là maintenant on facilite le
retour avec cette règle de suspension de
la quarantaine si vous êtes vacciné de
d'ores et déjà évidemment qui vont en
profiter
mais entre-temps recevra pas il
reprendre expocité avec les pays
étrangers
donc l'industrie de l'essai peut avoir
l'impression écoutez vous nous fait
perdre des clients domestiques vous ne
donnez pas plus des clients qui viennent
de l'étranger donc on est perdant deux
fois mais je le comprends très bien
parce que moi je suis député de la
région de québec la région québec et
l'industrie touristique est très forte
ici à québec c'est un haut lieu du
tourisme canadien et international
ceci étant dit les restrictions dont on
parle des récessions touristiques sont
des restrictions qui sont symétriques la
même chose s'applique pour les états
unis la frontière américaine est
toujours fermée pour les touristes
américains
la troisième chose c'est qu'on aura de
passer à une autre étape mais on est
passés plus rapidement si on peut passer
à travers cette pandémie
donc cet ulysse anita ça va de mieux en
mieux le canada est parmi les pays dans
le monde et pas et le premier dans les
pays du g20 en termes de vaccination
certainement deux premières d'aude
au québec on peut s'en réjouir on est en
avance sur notre agenda cours des deux
prochaines semaines toulouse millions de
doses ont été livrées aux canadiens donc
ça va très bien mais il faut patienter
encore un petit peu
alors on se demande quand est-ce que
vous allez autorisé justement la
réouverture des frontières avec les
états unis vous avez entendu peut-être
monsieur legault aujourd'hui que parler
de sa vision de celui dit bien d'accord
puis même content qu'on ouvre bientôt la
frontière avec les états unis misé à des
conditions et parmi ces conditions il ya
qu on exige que les personnes qui
viennent ici et reçu leurs deux doses de
vaccin
ça ça va demander toutes sortes de
négociations avec les états unis je
présume que vous les avez déjà commencé
ça doit faire partie de la liste des
sujets est-ce que ça va être facile de
conclure cette entente l'exigé
des américains vacciner quand ils
viennent ici au canada où magie
discussions avec ses vents ont cours
depuis un bon bout de temps les
américains comme nous on a hâte d'ouvrir
à la frontière un plus grand flux de
voyageurs d'un côté vers l'autre de la
frontière
j'ai gardé encore beaucoup d'étapes vous
savez on a dépassé les américains en
matière de vaccination on est en route
deux alors qu'on est parti un peu plus
bas au début parce qu'on n'avait pas de
production ici intérieur de l'accès mais
ça va très bien au canada n'est certes
pas toujours bien aux états unis donc
maintenant on a envie d'ouvrir la
frontière
il faut faire les choses correctement et
là ça passe entre autres comme l'avait
dit par l'établissement de règles
communes de technologie ou six communes
qui vont faciliter l'inscription
d'informations sur les vaccins pour que
les gens plus à voir la facilité mais
aussi la garantie de traverser à travers
les frontières mais en fait ce que
j'aimerais savoir de votre part c est ce
qu on s'en bat versol le canada ce qui
s'en va vers cette exigence demandée des
voyageurs qui ont deux doses de vaccin
pour les ressortissants américains qui
viendraient 127g pas possible parce que
les américains sont aussi 7
cette opinion qu'il faut du moins pour
un certain temps s'assurer que les gens
qui voyagent supérieure ces frontières
soient suffisamment vacciner pour se
protéger eux mêmes et aussi pour
protéger ceux et celles qu'ils vont à
l'elysée alors reste à voir maintenant
on le prouve comment vaccinale mais deux
jours d'ici la première c'est que ce qui
s'en vient le soir du 5 juillet c'est un
début de passeports vaccinale après ça
fonctionne par l'application arrive kahn
qui fonctionne bien une application
qu'on permettre aux gens d'inscrire
leurs informations de vaccination et le
poil est validée lorsqu'ils vont entrer
au canada mais il va y avoir plus que ça
parce que c'est une idée que j'ai une
première technologie développée
rapidement quand bien fonctionné dès
qu'ils ne soient pas aussi robuste que
ce qu'on va vouloir avoir à plus long
terme ce qu'on aura plus long terme ça
va être parfaitement un thé avec la
plateforme américaine est aussi l excès
elle que dont le pays développe dans le
monde parce qu'on a déjà des
technologies largement disponibles qui
vont nous permettre de faire ce travail
une meilleure collaboration efficace
avec l'ensemble des pays
une annonce cet été pour la réouverture
des frontières avec les états unis
bon on espère que les choses vont
continuer
il allait bien et d'aller le plus vite
possible on est focalisé sur l'opération
telle opération de vaccination pour
l'instant tous et toutes sont aussi
focalisé sur les mesures sanitaires
qu'il faut continuer d'adopter si on
veut se protéger et protéger les autres
et sortir le plus vite de la pandémie
mme bachelot merci pour cette entrevue
merci une bonne fin de soirée à vous
envoie pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici r d